economía en france24 me acompaña en el
estudio daniela brandon daniela buena
noche bienvenida la onu hizo un llamado
para que las mujeres sean más tenidas en
cuenta en la recuperación post pandemia
hola raúl muy buenas noches pues a
propósito del día internacional de la
mujer
naciones unidas- reconoce que la
pandemia ha tenido un impacto
desproporcionado en la población
femenina más que en la masculina han
tenido un desempleo mayor más carga de
trabajo en el hogar y aumento de la
violencia machista
la brecha venía incluso de antes de la
pandemia se estima que a nivel mundial
las mujeres ganan 23 por ciento menos y
están presentes sólo en una cuarta parte
de los parlamentos en el mundo además
únicamente 22 países tienen a una mujer
como jefa de estado o de gobierno
escuchemos
el coi 19 ha sido una calamidad para el
mundo para las mujeres y las niñas pero
también ha obligado a tener en cuenta
las desigualdades globales las
fragilidades y la arraigada
discriminación de género las mujeres
deben estar en el centro de la
recuperación mientras hacemos las
correcciones de rumbo que la pandemia ha
resaltado tan vívidamente pues ante esa
situación la cepal que es el brazo
económico de la onu para américa latina
propuso que se cree un ingreso básico de
emergencia para los 3 millones de
mujeres que perdieron su empleo por la
pandemia pero raúl este tipo de
propuestas no es nuevo y nunca ha salido
adelante así de sant hiela en chile van
a realizar el cobro de deudas a los
padres demandados por alimentos el
presidente sebastián piñera aprovechó
este día para enviar un proyecto al
congreso que plantea ciertas medidas
para aquellos padres que estén obligados
judicialmente al pago de una pensión
alimenticia y que no estén al día aplica
para quienes llevan tres cuotas
continuas o cinco discontinuas el
mandatario reconoce que el objetivo en
el fondo es hacerles muy difícil la vida
a los padres que quieran seguir
evadiendo
estas obligaciones entre las medidas
estarían entre otras raúl hacerles de
retenciones de los pagos por servicios
si son proveedores del estado rechazar
les la licencia de conducción o la
expedición del pasaporte según el caso
serán otras de las medidas así es
daniela pues a ponerse las pilas con eso
venezuela comenzó a racionar el difícil
para los camioneros esto se debe a la
baja producción nacional y a las escasas
importaciones desde eeuu
las restricciones comenzaron a notarse
desde el viernes cuando decenas de
camioneros bloquearon una de las
autopistas centrales de la ciudad de
maracay en el estado de aragua el país
habían experimentando una escasez
generalizada desde el año pasado lo que
obligó al presidente nicolás maduro a
recortar subsidios e importar
combustible desde irak aunque él dice él
todavía se distribuye a los camioneros
de forma gratuita
daniela eeuu se prepara para probar el
millonario plan de estímulos el sábado
el proyecto pasó la prueba en el senado
y este martes vuelve a la cámara de
representantes de mayoría demócrata lo
que se propone es un paquete de alivios
de 19 millones de dólares del total unos
400 mil millones de dólares serán
entregados en cheques directos miremos
raúl y los solteros con ingresos menores
a 80 mil dólares anuales y los calzados
con 160 mil dólares entre los dos
recibirán un cheque directo de 1.400
dólares este es el más grande entregado
hasta el momento después de 1% 1200
dólares y otro por 600 entregados el año
pasado también habrá beneficios
adicionales como la extensión del
programa de ayudas por desempleo hasta
septiembre y asistencia para el pago de
alquiler entre otros varios indicadores
en wall street' hubo cierres mixtos a la
espera de lo que suceda con el plan de
estímulos de este martes en europa las
bolsas de milán y de fráncfort sólo
tuvieron un repunte de más del 3 % esta
última batió récord histórico y en
américa latina la bolsa de buenos aires
cayó más del 2 por ciento y para
finalizar que nos trae como cifra el día
una cifra bonita raúl bonita 120
millones de flores
de 9.000 toneladas llegaron a rusia
desde mediados de febrero para celebrar
el día de la mujer este es uno de los
países con más tradición en este día y
se hizo importante tras la segunda
guerra mundial porque fueron elogiadas
por su heroico papel en la derrota de
los alemanes este año los rusos
compraron el doble de flores que el año
pasado y dos latinoamericanos estuvieron
dentro de sus principales proveedores
raúl ecuador y colombia así de danielle
y también más allá de flores respeto
para todas las mineras que por alto no
merecemos eso daniela muchísimas gracias
como siempre por toda la información
económica a ustedes también gracias
continua con nosotros y buena noche
[Música]